شوارع خلصان اخلاها 30,000 جندي روسي مع
اريتهم لكن اثارهم المزروعه بالالغام تؤرق
فرحه الاوكرانيين واحتفالاتهم بانتزاع
النصر الصعب عقب السعاده القوات
الاوكرانيه للمدينه الواقعه الجنوبي
البلاد حثت الشرطه سكان خرسون على التحرك
بحذر معلنه ابطال مفعول نحو الفي عبوه
ناسفه حتى اللحظه الاحتفالات باستعاده ما
يقارب ستنا بلده لم تخفي الدمار الكبير
الجاسم على المدينه فوفق الرئيس الاوكراني
دمر الروس كل البنا التحتيه الاساسيه وما
يشمله ذلك من اتصالات وامدادات مياه تدفئه
وكهرباء المحرره من القوات الروسيه تعاني
نقصا في المياه والادويه والطعام وهي
بانتظار الامدادات الطريقه طبعا مشاهدينا
القوات الروسيه لم تغادر قبل ان تتاكد من
تدبير كل ما يمكن تدميره خاصه لا يمكن ان
يخدم القوات الاوكرانيه نحو الضفه الاخرى
وتقدمها نحو هذه الضفه من نهر النيبرو فقد
اظهرت صور انهيار جسر انتونيسكي المعبر
الرئيسي من خرسون الى الضفه الشرقيه لدني
برو التي تسيطر عليها روسيا وسطر شحاته
بتدمير القوات الروسيه للطريق وجسر السكه
الحديديه المقيمين فوق نهر النيبرو خلال
العمليه وخلال عمليات الانسحاب اما سد
نوفا كخوفك الذي يضعوا 58 كلم شمال شرقي
خرسان فتعرض للضرر ايضا ما يرفع مستوى خطر
تعرض المدينه للفيضات يعيش اذا في خرفان
حاليا قرابه السبعين الى 80,000 شخص
مقارنه بعدد سكان هذه المدينه قبل الحرب
الذي كان يبلغ 23,000 نسمه وبعد الانسحاب
اي الانسحاب الروسي تعمل المدينه ان تحتض
عوده اهلها واهلها مشدده الى هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]